لم يصمد الحاجز الامني المضرب على هؤلاء
المحتجين كثيرا بعد محاوله منعهم وعدم
الترخيص ببعضهم بالتظاهر فتوجه الى شارع
الحبيب بورقيبه امتزجت هنا التيارات
السياسيه على اختلاف مشاردها وتنوعت
الشعارات المرفوعه لكن معارضه السلطه
القائمه وحدتها
يندد البعض بما يصفونه من حساره هامش
الحريه في البلاد وبما يعتبرونه قمعا
للمواطنين والناشطين السياسيين على حد
سواء
الازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الراهنه
كانت حاضره بكثافه في المظاهرات فاحتجى
المشاركون على ترد الوضع المعيشي للناس
وغلاء الاسعار وهي ببعض السلع عن الاسواق
رئيسي للحوار ويتعدى ويتكلم من الناس
الاعتراف الكل السياسيه وكل شيء ويلقى حل
الشعب هذا عبر المتظاهرون عن غضبهم ايضا
مما اعتبروه حكما فرديا للرئيس قيس سعيد
واتهموه بالفشل في تفسير البلاد فيما دعى
البعض الى توحيد جهود المعارضه لدفع سعيد
الى الرحيل
تونس سيتحقق حينما ينفذ اخواننا
الحسابات الصغيره ويرتقون الى المرحله الى
مستحقات المرحله وهي رحيل عيسى سعيد
اذا رغم اختلاف المرجعيات السياسيه لهؤلاء
المحتجين فان اغلبهم دعا الى اسقاط حكم
قيس سعيد والبحث عن حلول سريعه لازمات
يقولون انها باتت تهدد البلاد في الجهه
المقابله يبدو سعيد ماضيا في مساره غير
عابئ بالمعارضه ولا بمطالب طيف واسع من
التونسي ويتتهم معارضيه للخيانه والعمل
عملاء
تحقيق اراده الشعب في استرجاع امل الاموال
من الشعب بينما تبقى الهوت ساعه بين
الرئيس ومعارضيه تعاندوس ازمه اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه عميقه يخشى كثير من التونسيين
تداعيتها على البلاد حفظ مربح الجزيره
تونس